Jennifer Lopez opens up about her  boyfriend Alex Rodriguez oh my god as  her twin sealed the show time he got  dressed alike today she's my mini-me  yeah and we kind of dressed simile the  superstar singer is a guest on Mondays  Ellen DeGeneres Show she opened up about  her hot new romance with Alex Rodriguez  and dished on their first date he texts  me said let's go out to dinner I said  okay I don't remember well he ever  dinner what we had a nice dinner later  in the show JLo's adorable nine year old  twins Max and Emmie made an appearance  and even though Max was a little shy  they still showed off how cool they are  I understand y'all are texting now do  you have your phones and you're texting  yes do you text yes  [Applause]  you  [Music]